it is Friday and it's time for our last
Gamespot news show of the whole year
holidays are mere hours or days away but
before you get to that here's the gaming
news at mattered this
[Music]
week in super weird news Kim Kardashian
is now not the only mainstream celebrity
with a mobile game on the market thanks
to Lindsay Lohan now Lohan has something
more to do with video games than just
suing Rockstar her game the price of
Fame is free to play on IOS and Android
and is all about becoming a famous
celebrity so just like Kardashian's game
then which is still perplexing the
gaming masses by being Sadam popular the
point is to get fans dress up in your
expensive clothes and buy a pet snake or
whatever the controversial shooter drama
continues this week as upcoming title
hatred gets put on steam green light
taken off and then put back up again
valve boss Gabe newal said that they
made a bad call in deciding they
wouldn't publish the title he's now
personally apologized to the developers
and thrown the divisive title back up on
green light where it belongs or doesn't
belong depends on your
stance in things that are weird we use
have started to sell in droves thanks to
its big games and absurdly amiibo dumb
little plastic figures that you can put
in your game even I bought one Nintendo
has been riding the wave of Mario Kart
and Super Smash Brothers for a while now
and the Wii U just had its best ever
sales week since its launch in 2012
sales are up more than 90% year on year
for the console at the moment and about
700,000 amiibo have been sold across the
US in just their first month the
bestselling little plastic dude is link
followed by Mario and Pikachu probably
because those are the only ones anyone
can actually get in stores right now
[Music]
an analyst reckons Call of Duty is on
its way out despite Advanced Warfare
being the bestselling game in November
according to the NPD Piper jaffre
analyst Michael Olen said that act sales
fell 22% compared to November of last
year and cod's specific sales were down
27% explaining NPD data does not include
digital copies or International sales
which if included would lessen the
decline but we believe this data
suggests potential for Q4 Revenue upside
is now very
low after spending most of their time
focusing on the Xbox One Microsoft are
now saying it's time to start talking
about gaming on Windows Xbox boss Phil
Spencer said that January will be the
month of announcements for what will be
happening in regards to gaming on
Windows 10 the company already build the
platform as one that will serve all of
the company's products but as for what
that means precisely we aren't sure just
yet spener has spent this year saying
Microsoft should do more to support PC
gaming and The Gamers who prefer that
platform ask for your question of the
day let me know what's your platform of
choice for gaming and why this week on
site watch my just episode on this
year's biggest game delays Skyrim mod
gets in the Christmas spirit and reality
check takes on the cheat Bots that is it
for me for the year thanks for hanging
out and for all your support we'll be
back on January 5th of next year but be
sure to have yourself a lovely gamefield
break and I'll catch you again
[Music]
soon